if I'm a monk maybe I'll bring my Uniqlo
shorts we're those and the bald head you
know do you think all right do you think
these long raised socks you gave me -
for your Christmas and birthdays put
those on I keep all the socks do you
know what that is something so cute
about you he always shows up with a gift
and he always shows up wrapped and
there's always a little message there
yeah that he has acuteness about him
that you don't possess you're very like
focus you know throw money and he's
throw like he has so much like intent
and feelings behind his no he does he
really does yeah thank you that's the
nicest thing thus far tonight yeah let's
keep going to there you want uncle
positive you already deposit your New
Year's resolution
um well me and I'll uh we've been
talking about this my just my daily
habits and I need to change my sleeping
we didn't do that well in Arizona by the
way buddy what's handy what was a sleep
time was it in a 3 a.m. range no that's
early one time was 1 p.m. wake up with
your eyes bleeding what did you you fell
asleep okay first of all what tell him
but the worst of all
oh you might care okay okay oh yeah you
know one in he did the oh yeah yeah yeah
let me just say okay I show up okay and
the bed is the same bed that that John
McCain slept on when he was in the
Vietnamese camp wirebond literally is a
[ __ ] up all your [ __ ] arms yeah yeah
for more revenues yeah john mckenna came
and waved at lindsey graham on the
senate floor
[ __ ] that's okay and then not only that
is that at 6:00 a.m.
mmm the [ __ ] window you know what are
they the blinds
well there's on these panels right all
the ones that open and close yeah yeah
yeah you know the individually they're
attached
and then two of them had fallen out so
big gaps yeah so the Sun you [ __ ]
know it lasers in right where the gap is
into my face
oh it's missing those two yeah the -
that was right into my face yeah and
with this Cambodian but another
Cambodian sister by that Nigeria Nigeria
Niger
yeah always I always go you know you
know I don't want to do mix it up that
first I'm mixing it up okay
the Nigerian bed situation right this
[ __ ] sunlight I could not sleep till
one and I and I had a speech I'm not a
spiritual but I made a decision yeah I'm
gonna drop some money at this problem
okay he did an arts and crafts so we
went to Walmart yeah what I buy tell me
what I bought
dude he went to Walmart he got these
pure black poster boards yeah like 20 of
them
he bought like Gorilla Tape like the the
strong yeah oh these weren't new blinds
you would know no great [ __ ] the blonde
he straight went to the window and just
he barricaded he barricaded the whole
yeah I love blocking the shine but you
know ironically it runs in the family
cuz my mom's out no I thought my mom
he's gonna yell that way yeah and she
looked at it she goes good very good
walks away and then what else did I by
Fellowes oh no he bought a whole
comforter set
yeah oh dude I slept like a baby so it
felt like a whole so now the next night
oh my gosh like a 12-hour [ __ ] babies
deep sleep yeah yeah so are is this
something that's gonna change or are we
gonna go the we're not gonna do the monk
life anymore
so you're saying you got to change your
sleep habits like what is the reasonable
this ain't helping to the dipping do
much dude come on yeah I know what you
guys say about my breath you know he
tells no it's not I know it's the world
I know my breath let's do it I know my
blood raise your hand right and I want
everyone in this room everyone this will
raise their hand if you think my
brother's breath is the worst breath
you've ever smelled I'm gonna
two three one two three kalila why was
your hand right there I think it's about
you she complimented you really what
Bryce Bryce look at me he's never smoked
I've never smelled it
Bryce all right okay try it now or you
know kalila will bring up several topics
during the day what to eat hey Steve
Steve let me just start off by saying
that your teeth ain't nothing exactly
dude you put I'm not your dad
commercials from you dad these they fall
out on in his mouth - they do - Terry's
have to follow up yeah I just think that
like dental health directly affects like
your heart health and so I want you I
signed you up for insurance or I signed
you up for the paperwork can I see your
teeth let me you got some nice one oh
wow
yeah no braces your breath is like a
piece of [ __ ] took a piece of [ __ ]
but you know it's been a few days but
you know what it says I go I just came
in Altoids and he goes that would just
be like mint [ __ ] like wrapping gum
around a [ __ ] yeah yeah you can put
Christmas lights on a piece of [ __ ] so
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] justify you know when
it really is what's your testimony my
heart yeah my girlfriend I try to kiss
her in the morning yeah and like her she
went like her eyes got do you brush her
teeth like like you had SARS it's this
man the Grizzly choo ain't helping oh
maybe it's the Grizzly - man the last
time we went to the dentist together he
gave us the x-rays and everything and he
was like I haven't seen these kind of
teeth and let he goes let me pull them
all out in the back and you were like no
just pull out the one that hurts and I
told you Steve your brother will pay for
it all you're like nope nope
not the one only the one that hurts
people was that hurt man hurt yeah you
were not valid I don't know yeah just my
teeth I brush I brush I did you sure I
do diamond bro I was brushing the whole
time in Gilbert because you're a really
clean person you know what we're gonna
change that 2088 in the year the new
teeth using [ __ ] implants no actual
dental technology can they like cuz
these there's a lot of missing gaps
there's some gaps ooh you could just put
like implants and stuff they're like
fake teeth you could just yeah you
actually have to put something first
like anchor it and then you put the dent
bit over you think that's a good thing
yeah yeah
would that work though like if they had
that crazy kind of glue or you can just
put like a Chiclets in there or like say
anything you wanna do you want on there
yeah let's try it gorilla yeah really do
that all day Depot in there I was also
talking to in Hawaii because Paul Paul
Dave's brother went to visit and we're
sitting in the minivan together yeah and
I was talking to him and we're talking
about New York or something and he
didn't say anything he just offers me a
piece of gum yeah people people he was
trying to be nice about people know my
breath yeah your price you haven't
smelled it come on be honest I won't get
mad okay
no what smells on me but always [ __ ]
feel oh my god oh my god the swampers
you got small feet dude you're horrible
like a dead animals rotting underneath
there
mm-hmm because we're playing dude I
offered to put powder baby powder no
gold balls whatever they got and he goes
no dude no don't touch him cuz I like
I'm like what's that smell we're playing
a battlefront we're having a good time I
go what's that peculiar something yeah
let me smell your your his like little
slippers yeah and I would like this oh
my god so you know I I make him watch
the door he comes into bed there's
yeah there's a fungal infection
something deep one deep like it's in his
blood so how does it reach to that point
of smelling that bad ask him he has a
regimen well excuse me what's the asking
about it proper foot tongue is what why
don't you wear socks the itch the sock
it started with sauce my my my
problem started with the sock yeah I
wear the sock over a shoe and my feet
get really hot right and then I don't
know why but I carry I think it's from
the spa it's not because when I was a
swimmer I would get all sorts of weird
[ __ ] on my feet like I would get one of
those like those warts that go really
really deep inside I would get athlete's
foot because that that moist environment
and I'm not wearing slippers because I'm
a [ __ ] I was a dirty kid he's no he
doesn't wear slippers in the exact range
but my why didn't you explain my right
foot in perfect condition I don't know
maybe smells they both know I do every
time let me spell it right now no let me
just say this okay when I gave you the
slippers I made sure that you smelled
the left one I smell both yeah but one
of them wasn't as bad be honest they're
both pretty bad okay
these smell the same dude it's the same
smells the same smell on both right
black dude my shoe off in the airplane
he what do you mean one time that's like
every time you're ready from a different
app but you could be like three seats
over yeah three rows in back of me and
she'll go but no I I'll literally text
them like you need to put your [ __ ]
shoes
[Music]